Let's go beyond the legendary Fortnite skins.
Here are some of the rarest Fortnite skins
around.
The Reaper
The Reaper is the crown jewel of Season 3's
Hired Gun set, which just so happened to resemble
Keanu Reeves' character, John Wick, the infamous
assassin with a soft spot for puppies.
The Season 3 Battle Pass Announcement came
complete with The Reaper skin jumping from
an explosion, machine gun in hand.
"Yeah.
I'm thinkin' I'm back!"
Recon Expert
When Battle Royale debuted, players didn't
appreciate all the skins that were available.
One such example from season 1 is possibly
the rarest in the game: the Recon Expert.
Outwardly, she's not too interesting, and
didn't seem worth the initial 1,200 V-Bucks
cost.
But her rarity is directly connected to the
lackluster look, since no one bought the skin
before it disappeared from the shop.
Aerial Assault Trooper
Another Season 1 throwback, the Aerial Assault
Trooper was one of the first skins available
in Battle Royale, so only players who first
joined the game's hype train had access to
it.
Again, players missed out on the Aerial Assault
Trooper because of its lack of flash.
Despite not being one of the most exciting
skins, this one definitely has the power of
nostalgia behind it.
Renegade Raider
Renegade Raider is also from Fortnite's first
season, but this one has a little moxie.
After achieving Level 20, players could purchase
this outfit in the seasonal shop and were
probably drawn to her post-apocalyptic look.
Just as the Reaper resembles John Wick, Renegade
Raider recalls another movie character: Tank
Girl.
Keep your eye out if Epic decides to make
this available for late-comers to add to their
wardrobes.
Merry Marauder
Merry Marauder and his frowny-faced gingerbread
mask came with the Merry Christmas set.
These skins were only available for a limited
time, and while the Merry Marauder didn't
have the same fanatic following that the Halloween
skins did, if you didn't grab them at the
time, you'll never get to wear them — unless
Epic brings them back in the future to spread
some Christmas fear.
Black Knight
The Black Knight is the glowing-eyed scourge
of the Wailing Woods that was released as
a part of the Fort Knights set back in Season
2.
A just reward for those who achieved max level,
players covet it for the reputation points
it signifies.
And despite the Red Knight's later availability
in the shop, those who worked hard to get
the Black Knight skin still remain the only
players who've earned the exclusive right
to wear the armor of the darkest of the Fort
Knights.
The Galaxy
Galaxy is probably the most literally expensive
Fortnite skin, exclusive to owners of the
$650 Samsung Galaxy Tab S4, or the $1,000
Galaxy Note 9 phone.
The Galaxy skin was announced ahead of the
Fortnite Android Beta and quickly became a
fan-fave.
Ragnarok Skin
If you really want to be the Vi-king of Fortnite...you'll
probably have found some way to get the Ragnarok
skin during season 5.
Only available to players skilled enough to
kill their way up to Tier 100 that season,
Ragnarok is the mark of a dedicated player
and testament to how Epic Games' likes to
treat its best and most brutal Battle Royale
players.
Suffice it to say...it ragna-rocks.